alors pour moi l'art pub je vous réserve
c'est un peu compliqué mais le meilleur
élève pour moi c'est gilles verdez qui
est une vraie révélation pour son retour
il faut qu'il est beaucoup plus calme et
qu'il est extrêmement pertinent et j'ai
beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup de d'estimé et
d'admiration pour lui parce que je
trouve qu'il a une prise de parole
facile et qu' il est souvent très
pertinent et l'aubade élèves s'il faut
le dire il peut être moi en fait
franchement je ne suis pas très à l'aise
donc non je vous dirais moi parce que
j'ai rien à gérer à reprocher à
quiconque à cette table donc je trouve
que tout bon quand on sait pas on
démonte y ait une bonne équipe c'est une
équipe c'est une super équipe alors
meilleur et la font masser gg pour moi
ça a toujours été une des meilleures
élèves font c'est pas un honneur venant
de ma part mais en tout cas pour moi c
était une des meilleures et plus mauvais
élèves c'est bernard montiel mais
vraiment sans hésiter suce boules de la
terre ne sais pas quoi dire sur des mots
qui sont venus le père de son cerveau
insupportable c'est vraiment le plus nul
c'est pourquoi parce que ça s'est mal
passé tout à l'heure en loge mais
voulait mais quand même mais j'adore en
tout cas ça se savait recevoir vos amis
il n'en est vraiment pas pour ça qu'il
est bon chez onet avec mes amis nathalie
marquay alors pour moi c'est gilles
verdez le meilleur oui et non parce que
la tchaux aussi les bonnes infos il est
percutant et
il n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche et il
y va c'est bon et le moins bon élève et
ben c'est moi vraiment et masisi si
c'est moi je suis la moins expérimentée
même chose que c'est moi franchement
c'est fini ça voyez pas là franchement
sachez que des anciens jamais un ancien
se désignera lui-même pour moi la
meilleure elle survole l'année c'est
kelly kelly parce que quand elle parle
la lumière arrive pas ok avec fatou
parce qu'elle a des arguments pertinents
parce que ce haut cadre non non je
trouve voilà qu'elle est excellente et
dès qu'elle est là c'est différent donc
c'est kelly et qu'elle est tu le croises
ce qu'il vient de dire mais on a un truc
gilles et moi ah bon jalloud a non loin
d'aix est loin d'être sexuelle faut le
savoir il s'appelle au gilbert des le
pire oui c'est montiel franchement cyril
vous adorent mais comment faites vous
pour le faire venir chaque fois rejetées
avait été testé que j'adore bernard
pottier léger à faible allure oui c'est
mon petit chouchou oui mais c'est le roi
des branleurs il retravaille jamais y
arriver ne sais même pas ce qu'il va
dire oui c'est le vide incarne
évidemment c'est la pire niveau allant
moi le meilleur c'est guillaume genton
elle veut pécho elle aussi je suis même
quand je suis pas d'accord avec lui et
ça arrive souvent ne trouve toujours
pertinent étayé est toujours calme
d'accord a contrario parce que je vais
pas me désigner moi même parce que vous
savez pas que des fois je tourne qu'à
dire mais donc pour moi le pire c'est j
parce qu'il est toujours surexcité et
pour mille à côté ça me gonfle toujours
jeunes téléspectateurs et 2h13 enfin
conseils de classe et d'un enfant qu'on
a fait un conseil de classe on a perdu
deux chroniqueurs de guerre ces
dernières que va-t-il se passer et de
coeur c'est bernard l'accord merci
bernard monte alors pour moi les
meilleurs élèves c'est vraiment
guillaume genton d'accord il est
vraiment très bon il parle très très
bien il est très clair c'est vrai que
c'est souvent les nouveaux les meilleurs
élèves il est très bien elle est très
claire il faut le garder et
vous croyez qu'on vous écoute c'est pour
ça que je le dis comme on m'écoute et le
plus mauvais alors j'ai lire moi je
travaille énormément mais j'arrive pas à
en placer une
donc c'est toujours un peu difficile
c'est regarder je travaille mais bon je
trouve que toujours les autres
s'expriment mieux que moi donc je n'ose
pas y aller c'est vrai c'est le plus
mauvais et bien moi non vous pouvez pas
dire ça sinon moi j'ai du charme et j'ai
du charme et ça n'a rien à voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]